pour la gloire pour l'argent dans une
forme de sport spectacle dont le haut
lieu et le crazy horse saloon de paris
quelques jeunes femmes qui s'appelle
bizarrement lova moor un des regrets
d'autres surnoms disputent chaque soir
une compétition où elle s'assure tous
les suffrages du public masculin martin
de bars y en a rencontré quelques jeunes
bonjour le modèle en son genre comment
vous appelez-vous je m'appelle paul de
blaye nez rouge par l'hymne du club
[Musique]
ali traoré
pourquoi s'il vous plaît parce que je
suis artiste du corry jane je suis je
suis d'enfants des analystes ont dit en
effet c'était le contraire l'érotisme
parce qu'elles jouent elles dansent
jouent avec leur corps ce sont des
professionnels du mouvement et ce
mouvement
à bize le corps elles ne sont pas nues
maladroitement ils ne sont pas nues
comme et le numéro 6 elles sont nulles
avec art et l'art les habits je n'avais
pas de complexe je veux pas de complexe
contre mon corps je te coupe la pluie
peut faire comme tout le monde a des
complexes mais j'ai pas des complets à
partie de mon corps
[Musique]
je m'appelle lova moor
c'est pas moi non non c'est monde en
guerre sinon que monsieur bernard dame a
donné enfin que lens et du cruiser selon
mais quel est votre vrai nom mon vrai
nom et jourdain au prénom et
marie-claude green bay qui table sur
10,1 en date sur la scène du crack leur
salut je deviens une autre personne
beaucoup plus agressive beaucoup m'a dit
qu'elle avait vu et je crois que je me
fabrique un personnage dans la vie vous
êtes timide dans la vie oui je titille
les commence mme dufay ses activités je
parle très peu lorsque je connais très
peu les gens qui me qui me parle je
recherche c'est facilement et se
maintenant des gens je suis un signe est
ce que vous êtes plus dick
oui beaucoup tu les as de la scène
timmy est [__]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce que l'homme de votre vie est
jaloux non je ne pense pas heureusement
et les hommes les jeunes français quand
ils savent qu on fait ce métier là
quelle est leur action et qui sont
naturels le plus souvent elles demandent
pour voir le spectacle si je peux pas
avoir une option et vous la randonnée
fiche un peu oui
quel est votre conclusion de sociologues
ma conclusion c'est que finalement ce
n'est pas un spectacle de sources
populaires au fond je dirais que chaque
individu qui se plaît et profondément ce
spectacle il y à un pari sur une sorte
de phallocrate rentiers qui sommeille